donc je voudrais d'une part contre
ce mur fonctionne un peu cependant
d'autre part, les agriculteurs pour
sont de sensibiliser pour dire
peut-être que vous avez bien entendu
et ne commence pas petit, dit Stürmer
pas du tout mais oui signifie que je suis
julia nissen 33 annuler ici et je suis
blogueur de la vie à la campagne ici
Nordfriesland j'écris tout ce qui me vient
L'étable de la cuisine de l'enfant vient devant l'objectif
gens de la vie à la campagne
[Musique]
mon blog s'appelle apprendre leur est un
Terme bas allemand à savoir signifie
la fille et sa grand-mère m'emmenaient
appelé et parce que nous sommes maintenant là depuis que je
vivre et oui en quelque sorte il y a moi
c'était en quelque sorte très concluant
et c'était le nom que je vais expliquer
le blog très bien où les choses
Viens ici donc j'ai des sujets
mois thèmes agricoles mois
où j'explique j'explique un mois
complètement sur un sujet de pomme de terre
un mois complètement sur le sujet
alors il y a quelque chose pour garder les cochons
sujet élevé il y a ce que nous avons maintenant
il y avait juste à ce moment-là nous avons pris le thé
mois moi actuellement nous sommes maintenant dans
grain et dans la saison des récoltes et là
sont juste parce qu'il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
donc nous ne sommes même pas avec elle
chariot sur le chemin des images encore en quelque sorte
la motivation est suggérée
juste pour montrer ici combien ça vaut la peine d'être vécu
qu'elle est sur la terre que nous sommes aussi
internet a tout ça
clichés, parfois oui, toujours
publicité toujours être servi que le gar
n'existe plus ou nous
qui eux-mêmes aussi que de l'histoire et
Oui, je voulais juste faire le pont
formulaire
[Musique]
le fermier meurt
puis créez votre offre et disons
offrir une visite de la ferme
le jour ou moi mais peut faire plus
maintenant juste quelqu'un pour une journée
les vendanges à pied et avec tracteur
conduire ou vouloir me quelqu'un peut-il avec
cuisiner ensemble ou avec moi
aller chasser ensemble ou ou ou
et puis je peux dire que c'est
intéressant me convient que je
réservez-le et vous êtes deux
à trois clics du ticket
[Musique]
les clivages entre ville et campagne
peut-être qu'ils grossissent
inconsciemment et on éduque sur cette application
entre autres juste un autre
petit pont arrière dans lequel on peut aussi monter
différents milieux de vie simplement
et peut mais ce n'est pas comme ça
que les citadins ou pas dans la cour
venez vivre quelque chose mais ça
sert les deux côtés à cause de chacun
En tant que prestataire, j'accepte aussi les rencontres
toujours quelque chose avec moi je suis de bonnes personnes
réunir donc sont en fait comme ça
un entremetteur classique et apporter
j'aime les gens ensemble j'aime l'étranger
des gens pour nous asseoir
donc je vois ce qui se passe là
voudrais être contre celui-ci
les agriculteurs dénigrent mais travaillent de l'autre
mais aussi les agriculteurs pour sont fermés
sensibiliser et dire que c'était le moment
pour bien vous entendre n'avez pas de minibus
herbes n'est pas du tout mais si
un si l'on écoute bien et s'en sort
dépend de la nature de l'information
maintenant important pour moi là-bas
a été prise et comment régler
préparer mon entreprise pour l'avenir
ce n'est plus la conséquence
est alors nous avons tous
en quelque sorte gagné je suis là
toujours très loin derrière
ferme et peut-être qu'il est
avec le coeur mais je les comprends aussi
côté consommateur et souhaite juste
parce que des deux côtés plus plus à entendre
et un en conséquence
[Musique]